the question is what do we do if we have
a particular formalism that doesn't have
these
properties so the underlying idea of
this talk is then sometimes we can just
change the rules of game so whenever I
talk here about cheating in this talk I
don't want you to think about something
mean but something
innocuous something like think about a
professor who says I don't want to teach
paxos let's just see what happens and
run with it the same is this here if if
we have something that doesn't fulfill
certain properties we love and we like
can we can switch a little bit things so
we have everything we we we want to have
back yeah so cheating is something in
this case not mean not
harmful so the overall Focus um all
focus with a very general problem
semisupervised not classification we
assume we have given a network with a
couple of labeled notes and now what we
want to do is we want to assign the
appropriate type label color to all all
the remaining uncolored nodes so we
assume there's something some
unobserved um references going on so
certain kind of nodes prefer other nodes
higher than than than different types of
nodes so for example if you look at this
one you may see that the green nodes
like to hang out amongst themselves but
the orange ones like more blue ones and
vice versa and the way you can think
about this um let's just so let's just
count the number of edges of a certain
type and if you do this you will see
well amongst the orange nodes you will
see about yeah exactly there are 12
different types that point to a blue
node so you can think about this is and
the way I want you to think about this
is some kind of affinities preferences
some probability
distributions compatibilities frequency
tables so for example amongst um amongst
the the orange ones let's see this
works the orange ones you see that well
60% of the orange edges outgoing edges
to point two blue
ones so now in real problemy also often
have node
attributes for the purpose of this point
this talk we assume there no node
attributes so they only look at the
relational information the graph
structure no
attributes and then there are two
variants of the problem we're going to
study the first one given the network
given the seed noes and given the known
compatibilities how can we label all the
remaining
nodes and the second time we then relax
this and say we don't have the
compatibilities we don't know we only
observe the network now we want to learn
first these compatibilities and then we
use it with some meod to label the
remaining nodes so these are the two
problems we're going to
study
okay so let's do this in turn the first
one so what did we start we start with
um an algorithm that's widely known in
in probity graphic models belief
propagation and is called something it's
a dynamic programming algorithm that
works on a Tre based graphical model and
for reasons that we have seen already
several times in this in this um um in
this Workshop Fun's idea about local to
Global consistency we have seen Nikos
damic programming algorithm so what is
the idea the idea of this algorithm
intuitively
is and why we like trees is because
every node is connected to every other
node with exactly one
path so if s sends a message to T then s
is basically the root of the sube of all
the other nodes from that direction so
the algorithm proceeds in the following
way it accumulates it
accumulates so it accumulates all of the
messages from the
neighbors then adds its own beliefs and
then prepares a message to be sent from
s to T the interesting thing is now that
the message gets modulated with the
potential so for example if you're green
um then we we giving the
highest frequency to other green
nodes you can think about these
compatibilities is a probability
distribution
okay now here's the exact formalism we
don't need to pass this but that's the
intuition so the notes accumulates all
of the messages it multiplies the
messages it multiplies it its own belief
and then it modulates transforms them
over all of the possible state it has
and then sends the message and then this
whole thing gets um sent around until
hopefully things converge guaranteed to
converge like a s joint reduction in um
a cyli
schemas but real world problems are in
the graph based World usually not a
cyclic and we seen if we have now Cycles
then things do not work very well so
what do people do um people cheat so
people cheat and say actually um let's
just run these algorithms on graphs with
Cycles that's also called Loops so it's
called Loop P Le propagation so people
run this on on on grass with loops and
surprisingly it works quite well when it
works but it doesn't always work and um
it's a long literature where people have
basally um observed it works really well
however sometimes it does not work if we
have certain Loops it's really
complicated to make this algorithm work
so the idea if you're already cheating
if you're already using an algorithm
that is not actually made for loops why
do we don't cheat in the appropriate
way so when it doesn't work you mean
that it doesn't convert correct it
doesn't
convert um actually excellent I will
show the basic idea is what we're going
to do we're going to flip this so we're
going to change this we're going to
cheat a little bit in a more informed
way and then we get some formalism that
turns out to generalize Pat rink in a
very nice nice way
perh does exist the cover of the graph
that work well so this would be the Bas
we can apply the the computation so I
think what you say is the if you have a
graph if you have a um um cylic graph
you just look for a spanning tree but
imagine like you have a really dense
graph everybody is connected to 100
friends you a very dense one then assume
the number of edges that you have is it
really reflective because very often you
want to also have triangles which
everybody is excited about in this so we
want kind not of throw away the edges
and connections we want to leverage this
but we don't want to run into this
problems we want to have some nicer
properties maybe we want to have
something like that we learned from
jaier um who was here yes do things
converge can we have some fix points so
that's what we did so how do we cheat um
we linearize we linearize the equations
of page
rank um because then we change it into
some algebraic convenient form it turns
out based to fla expression that this is
a very nice intuitive generalization of
patrank to something that's called
heteropoly homop means
um people of same orientation like to
Cluster itself green nodes important
Pages linked to other important Pages
here maybe opposites of direct there so
if you look at biological networks and
you want to substitute a particular um a
protein you may want to substitute with
something that is the same function
these two may not actually interact with
each other but they have the same
friends but they're not friends
themselves and it turns out in the more
modern language but you get is like an
infinitely deep graph n networks that
has no nonlinearities this goes back to
bares but let's see if it works out
fine okay so what is what we're doing me
two pages what we're doing is so
basically we're looking at the all of
these different um variables that I've
shown
you the compatibilities the belief the
messages these are the three things that
get sent around in this formalism and
then we identify some uninformative
point so if I give you this Matrix
compatibilities you don't learn much I'm
orange well one f one thir that you're
orange blue or green and the same with
probability distributions and with the
messages so here one it's a bit more
careful and then we look at the
difference at the residual and then we
formalize the whole equation system in
terms of this
residuals and then we're going to use
tailor expansions so M laen series we
look at the particular things that are
happening in the equations and we
approximate
then so the nice things happen here's
the intuition of what's Happening behind
this is um the original formalism
multiplies the different
messages so you get here Z five when we
need to normalize and it turns out that
normalization is one of the complicated
things that make page rank so
complicated
if you change it we have a different
normalization
constant that's the key thing what we
looking into is actually at the
residuals and then we place
multiplication with addition and
intuitively what we get gives us the
same flavor right so 69% or 70% but the
prediction is still the same the first
class
wins but now we have a very nice um
equation system that has addition m and
everything is normalized by
Design so we get and this goes back to
flow question is actually very nice
intuitive update
equation so so what we have is any
possible Brier beliefs those are the
nodes which are already labeled we have
the adjacency Matrix f is the beliefs we
want to have at the end and F is this
compatibility Matrix now to flor's
question is um
if you now compare this with page rank
that's pretty much the same yeah the
difference is that we don't have the
column normalized Matrix but just the
Matrix itself that's also called um cut
centrality in social network
analysis and a little bit other things
but now what we have is um we
can investigate this equation systems
with the tool that we also heard from
cier um and it turns out we we can say
actually we can give a closed form
solution we can study when these
equations actually
converge so and and intuitively exactly
if here this expression has a spectral
radius smaller than one means the
biggest eying value is smaller than one
and the intuition behind this um let me
just remind you about the example we saw
from cavier I think you use the a for
this right 1 + a plus x^ s um geometric
series and we know exactly when it's
convergence
so if you have2 it converges minus 12 if
you have two it does not converge
because the spectral radius equivalent
the absolute value is bigger than
one and that's actually this this is
intuitively the same what we see here
yeah one is the identity Matrix and here
we have a conical B between two two
matrices yes to make
the yes exactly so that's what we do
basically is so if so cheating so if
something does not have this the the
spect R we want we just Tor it down a
little bit just barely that we just
don't run into the nonon issues so
that's exactly what we
do so what we lose um in experimental
results not
much I have your backup slide just in
case so this means so actually if One
Compares with belief propagation in the
police in certain assumptions in certain
um situations one does not too much but
the best things are still to come um and
then one more thing is also because um
Joe has shown us some example Cote
belief propagation is quite nasty to
implement and we have seen that if you
change something different formalisms
you can just Express something in very
few line of code how many lines of code
do we need for the belief
propagation just
one this today you can do as a p to this
was just NP but you see exactly this
update equations right so dot product
you have a spar representation with
number and that's what you have so it's
really just one line of quote and let me
know the big picture this best The Best
Is Yet To Come um so what what is the
overall picture here so if you look at
bistic inference bistic inference is
hard so the model and from inference in
practice we have to approximate
it now if you want to learn a model we
normally have to use the same algorithm
that we perform an inference on training
data so this means if the inference is
hard the learning is also hard because
learning normally uses inference or sub
routin cross entropy back propagation qu
and descent um
approximations so I assume that
G from the second Workshop we had people
would say does this really make sense
right but we've learned from the whole
ideas from from um compilation why do we
compile knowledge into a model that is
complicated to work
with because inference is hard and
learning is hard can we just replac this
here that's the idea so we replace it
with a
model that we prefer because out of
algebraic
convenience so and the interesting thing
is then now we have some very easy
inference because of the properties but
the best is actually we can also make
learning fast yeah and to use also an
expression from CH crazy fast so promise
you this stuff is going to be really
really fast
yeah so I'll show you how fast this is
so um so here's how long does it take to
propagate um information to perform
inference unsurprisingly it's um it's
linear in the number of edges the bigger
Network you you send more for the
network how well does it work if you
have fewer labeled data points also
unsurprising if you have few and fewer
labeled data then the propagation gets
more and more diminished and it's not as
accurate yeah so here for example we
have just 10 labeled noes in a graph of
10 um 10,000 notes so um one per Mill of
labeled notes if you use the standard
textbook
approach we need more time to learn the
parameters because we use inference as a
sub routine and at the same
time we get a drop an
accuracy because if we have some some
hold out set we need to fit the data we
have few data to fit then we also have
to to buy properly this so what I'm
going to show you in
contrast is fast
inference so actually in a in a fraction
of the time we need to propagate from
inference we can learn the parameters
and it's also as accurate as if we had
the original um data points we have just
10 data points in a in a graph we learn
the compatibilities and propagate them
we get the same thing as if we had known
them from the
beginning so so what is the
trick so the idea is that we we we
separate learning into two
steps so we want to learn these
compatibilities but we first create some
efficient representations of the graph
think about this factorized graph
representations you perform some
statistics that are very small and
Compact and then we perform the learning
on this more compact representations and
the first part is actually just linear
inside of the graph but the second part
the optimization which may take more
time is done just in the size of these
representations so really
fast
questions yes
okay I was wondering the picture that
you have before the Red AR the
complicated approach to Computer
Solution and the green one that are the
easy
one one of the question that sometimes
we have on machine learning why the
model give this explanation and there
are some approach line some three
classification and so in order to to
explain why the model with this
difficult methodology inside I give this
his result I wondering if you using the
green the green arrow let's say a more
easy a more easy way to compute the the
the solution give also an easy and more
human intelligible and explainable way
to to yeah so most definitely I think
quite excent this I think goes also back
to um TX talk and then I think Boris
question so if we have everything linear
then we back in the same earing
framework and everything we know very
well how this works these people by line
people try to have something complicated
approximate it linearize it amongst the
point and then try to give in two
explanation so I agree with
yeah but you're linear right you don't
have activation
function lariz why did you mention
networks I will come to this at my
discussion slide so um actually um so
the question is should I jump to to to
the discussion or should I still show
you what we actually do
um so um I think I have oh 10 minutes
okay so here's what we would like to do
but it doesn't work and then we're going
to tck it a little bit so that it works
yeah so here's the thing is if we have a
fully labeled graph then we can do
exactly what I showed in the beginning
which are to Counting we just count the
number of edges of of pairs of different
colors and we can the normal this and
then we are
done now what happens if we have a spy
labeled
graph is if we have yeah what we could
do is we could still just look at the
neighbors here we have just two
neighbors we calculate the statistics
and then we still want to normalize it
and find the closest dou to sastic
symmetric Matrix under some distance
function the problem with this is that
if you have a sp labeled graph so assume
I give you 10% labeled notes
what is the fraction of edges we have
lab on both
sides so 10% independently
chosen then 10% * 10% is 1% so we just
have 1% so if this goes down we get
fewer and fewer data points from which
we
get this is the idea yeah a quick
detailed slide of how this could be done
yeah so in the spirit you can calculate
in a spar framework just with with one
pass over the data the label types of of
no of different color you can normalize
it so that the the the the row sum up to
one and then a simple optimization
problem under L2 Norm to find and fit
the
closest but this doesn't work if we have
very few label noes so what is the idea
but theb the idea is that we now look at
just further distances so think about
one one particular notes and orange
nodes orange this means the entry this
is orange what do we expect about its
neighbors if it is out degree too well
that's
basically that is this entry of the
Matrix we want to
learn as we go further and further away
the strength of the signal gets
diminished but we have an
exponential number of neighbors of a
certain distance so this gets weaker and
weaker
but we get more and more information and
we're more likely to have more neighbors
that's the
idea that's that's Bally all what what
there is to it and the nice thing about
this is now um now we have actually here
with the distance we can recover the
very few neighbored nebor this is a
local computation because you only see
your
neighbor distributed fashion or
not so can one do it in a distributed
fashion I because everything just gets
it's like a linear algebra expression
which need to be compiled the distance
we go up to distance five if you have
like a uh a graph that has a diameter of
five then everybody's connected to
everybody and we somehow want to
calculate this efficiently and we come
to about how we calculate this
efficiently in a
moment and and basally the idea is now
we do something very similar to what I
showed it before yeah so we we create an
energy function where we get the
statistics from different length pass
and then we try to we just we just look
for the closest one the closest um
Matrix H that fits all of these
different statistics we get for Paths of
different length 1 two 3 four five in
this case we could f it down to get
better
results so that's fine but there's two
things actually that are still not
correct the first thing what I just told
you is actually not working because if
that's what we want and we do and we see
actually we get a biased
estimator why do we get a biased
estimator because what's happening is um
if I tell you that every node has an out
degree
two then a distance two path is actually
back to the node so this means we get a
B estimator because the most frequent
label of a node of distance two is
itself so we need to be a bit more
careful and only look at um what's
called non-backtracking path so be more
careful about what we calculate only
those paths which don't directly
backtrack over over any of the distances
that we calculate the second thing is
and this goes back to um stano's
question about um a graph if you now
want to calculate all of the so if if W
is a sparse Matrix yeah big but
everybody's connected to a constant
number of of neighbors now if you
calculate the The Matrix to the powers
of of higher up and higher
up Bly get us dense Matrix so n to the
power of two
but how we can use all our beloved
algebraic properties the basic ideas of
V Bally an agregate query it's an
aggregate query that we can factor in a
way to calculate very efficient we can
Calculate 10 to the^ 14 power in a in in
a few
milliseconds and the idea for this is
exactly what this workship is about so
if I give you for example here a
relational um algebra expression then we
know that we can push the project
ction behind the
join the same we can do also with this
linear algebra expression if I tell you
that this is here a spar Matrix you want
to calculate this expression this is
here thin label
Matrix minut what do we
do we apply the law
of
stivity why because then we're
guaranteed that our intermediate results
this is a common topic that we've seen
throughout this this program we want to
calculate something the outcome is very
small right we want to have a three *
three Matrix we don't want to calculate
intermate results ases are the big so
how do we do this well we we keep them
small but having the right approach of
how to factor so exactly the same idea
of FAQ um we need to be more careful
about because of this non backtracking
path but the idea is exactly this idea
that seen throughout this uh Workshop
um that if it doesn't in the right way
you can calculate very efficiently yeah
so the fq framework generaliz dist law I
think tomorrow um J is also talking
about what J mner and and him is doing
with associative arrays okay so
discussion question that um foror said
um how does this relate to graph NE
Network so I've used this here this is a
slide many of you have seen who looked
at graph new network this from the from
the um lectures night from ovich is also
something that um suck had in this in
this in this Network so you want to
calculate something about this graph
graph NE networks think about unwind
this into something Al stano like a Dre
based um yeah and then in each of these
different boxes you have some Neal
Network that does something yeah and the
basic idea of this um graph
convolutional networks was that you have
here some new networks and at the end
you fit this with cross entropy there
was some work that's called let's
simplify this a simplify simplified
graph convolution says well you know
what we don't actually need to have here
nonlinearities we just keep this linear
and they just have one nonlinearity at
the end this this the soft Marx function
at the end to fit the data that we have
and it seems to work as well so we came
from a different part from belief
propagation and said H can we simplify
it but if I now looks at what this
actually is you could say this is
nothing this say because we have now
exact guarantee a button it converges
it's like a craft neur network with
infinite layers and we are guaranteed to
avoid over smoing because we know
exactly the convergence
guarantees so that so that's um for open
topics last slide so one thing is
there's a lot of focus in actually most
of the papers in bra networks so so one
lesson is the more data you draw at a
problem the better you can fit so you
now compare this with approaches that
use also not attributes it won't be as
good but how much do we learn I think
one question by itself that is not
completely clear is actually how well
can we learn information from a given
Network without attributes because
attributes there so many Essentials
attributes you use some outside um
learned the large language models but
then you bring out information from
something else how much information is
actually available in a g in a g um in a
given
graph without the attributes I think
this is something that's worth to study
and then basically what kind of effect
you can have that make the linear
methods so that you're losing something
but actually how much do you lose in
practice really if you have like a
phenomenon that is just based on just
preferences from Neighbors are higher
effects that cannot be as well
represented and then basically yeah what
are then the appropriate architectures
that can learn just based on the graph
no attributes assuming certain certain
effects okay with this thank
[Music]
you time for one
question all right well there will be
questions after the in the um session
for discussion after the next so a welld
deserved
break